salut jake je peux avoir une grande
bouteille de bail joues tu sais quoi
balance moi deux grandes bouteilles
comment tu arrives à boire autant je me
plaignais d'avoir à subir chaque jour la
même chose maintenant tous les jours
c'est pareil
je suis mort 144 fois et chaque jour se
termine comme ça mais ça n'a pas
d'importance pas quand vous avez perdu
tout ce que vous aimiez
vanthoor l'homme qui m'a déjà tué 150
fois le pouvoir de réécrire l'histoire
et le méga je sais tout ce qui va
m'arriver
et pour toi roj tu m'entends bien
la seule femme que j'ai jamais mais qui
peut arrêter ça est encore en vie
je dois me faire tuer encore et encore
jusqu'à ce que je l'a sauvé
je dois apprendre à me battre à l'épée
je n'ai qu'un jour à vous consacrer je
crois qu'on peut faire beaucoup en un
jour
[Musique]
je suis vous spirale mortelle à cause de
toi c'est exact
qu'ils amènent tous jusqu'au dernier
[Applaudissements]
peut faire ça toute la journée
[Musique]
amateur passionné
merde
[Musique]
non
rien
[Musique]
cobac de file td oui comme meilleure
salle
[Musique]
johansson cinq prix
m
que 5 du box pack à venir
autant
[Musique]
que s'est il passé ta cabane
la recherche se poursuit pour quatre
détenus qui se sont échappés de la gare
de cd rom attention deux gardes armés d
un détenu alors qu'elle fuyait les
autorités affirment que les impôts garde
est extrêmement dangereux
éteins ta musique s'il te plaît
qu'est ce qu'elle fait là elle c'est
très gentil de partager ton père avec
nous non
tu la laisses tu marches et il a 13 ans
je cherche une clé est là ce symbole
gravé dessus vous l'avez vu non alors il
me reste mais qui web et qui
attendait non
il va tenir ton père tranquille pendant
que juif et du mal
on va les laisser s'en tirer comme ça la
clé à taboye alors plus
[Musique]
compétitive at elle été sortie
vraiment les spéciales
alethea
[Musique]
bah
oh
ml
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous saviez qu'il existait deux sortes
de lumière celle que l'on voit à
l'extérieur et celles qui se trouvent
dans votre coeur je vais vous raconter
comment j'ai appris à faire la
différence entre les deux
je suis tiers mayans la luciole et je
viens vous aider carmat
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette chose moi je vous dis
que c'est 1 2 jamais l or c'est pas pour
me vanter mais je suis une série nick
dans mon jeu c'est vrai sa lumière
pourrait très vite se déplacer moi aussi
j'ai à la famille
[Musique]
c'est trop bien mais clément puisque
carnaille
les fourmis ont été cambriolés hier soir
elle restait bien né voici les aliments
qu'on a volé au village il nous faut
quelqu'un de courageux pour nous
protéger
[Musique]
ne les laissez pas s'échapper
m
[Musique]
il est roi mais il a choisi sa date
d'anniversaire comme on le fait tous
[Musique]
il faut que je te vire à ton âge c'est
toujours pas mieux que ça c'est sans
espoir
je veux que tu penses à tous les autres
enfants à qui on a dit qu'ils étaient
soit trop petits soient trop lent
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est jules
créons notre propre équipe
il nous faut juste une patinoire
vous êtes perdus si vous voulez louer
des patins c'est à l'accueil
dites moi que la plupart du temps ce
sont les outsiders du yen faut que tu
prennes le taureau par les cornes
qu'est ce que ça peut vous faire vous en
souffrez
[Applaudissements]
banier
découvrir une toute nouvelle espèce les
bouche trous
des animaux trop mignon joueur
est très intelligent
cette année
les bouche-trous débarque chez vous si
jamais vu un endroit pareil
tu es là c'est le piscine ah non c'est
trop dangereux mais
pousse trop
voyage complètement d'un idéal
allez viens on a encore plein de vieux
inspecté alors on reste concentré pour
sauver leur espèce
on est les seuls à pouvoir sauver les
bouche trous de l'extinction pauvres de
nous
oc claque
on sera considérée comme des ronds
perle est
les bouche trous on va tomber montant
[Musique]
aidera les gars et estaing 2010 dans des
délicieux bientôt au cinéma
quelqu'un d'une
[Musique]
victoire chacun applique seymour sa
manie de
la fraîcheur si pas d'accord devant
mettre d'accord et si vous les enfermer
aujourd'hui vous les condamnez à la
délinquance et sa cravate rouge à dabou
a longtemps dû
qu'est-ce que ça à faire à part insulter
les forces de l'ordre eh bien on va les
occuper
ce chat les travaux d'intérêt général
bien réalisable l'institut des aveugles
et malvoyants et si on apprend à
regarder la réalité en face
viandes poissons qu'est-ce que vous
criez
yaura du temps voilà qui vient beaucoup
de malentendus
c'est dur
il ya un moment dans l'avion prend une
décision on a joué en couleurs ici ils
ont tous choisi de nager il ya une
piscine aussi way aller les blues là on
rentre on a pêché le bus fait quoi
autant quand on est dans la droite mike
wallace y faire c'est bien venir
ici pour les entraîne dans un organisme
à pied avec des groupes ont alors
concerné pas débattre c'est quoi cet
espoir que tu leur donnes tu crois que
tu fais les transformant footballeur en
cette semaine je te rends compte ou pas
carrément en train d'apprendre à faire
du foot à des aveugles
tirer
si on réduit nos formations ont réduit
aussi leur chante crois que ça nous
amuse nous aussi on s'est battu pour cet
institut et vous vous en parler au passé
[Applaudissements]
quand la bise mais dans mouvement et
vous toujours un chemin
n'est ce pas
je
[Applaudissements]
j'ai roulé au liban puis je vous
orienter attention nous a signalé la
présence d'une suisse dans l'eau captée
bienvenue à l'iss ont chanté à lester la
leur et
vous comptez retourner vivre dans votre
pays je n'ai pas l'impression que ma
place soit là bas et vous a des rêves de
voyage je suis en train de travailler
sur un projet de fusée j'espère un jour
envoyer le premier libanais dans
l'espace
[Musique]
est-ce que se passe
je crains que plus rien ne sera comme
avant dans ce pays que tu attends tu
aimais
[Musique]
dissoute non
prend l'avion pour paris ce mardi depuis
n'existera sûrement plus dans une
semaine c'est sûr qu'ici personne croix
rouge de rester
[Musique]
il fallait s'y attendre ce onzième
cessez le feu ne va pas durer plus de
quelques jours et amoureuse
je suis rejoindre saviez je vais partir
pour la france
alice glass est ce que c'est parce que
nous avons trop ri que nous n'avons pas
eu le courage d'affronter nolan
j'ai joué toute la famille visite laisse
pas abordé d'affiché
avant